hello and welcome to this video I did
not start the recording so no I did
I hope did I do it yeah so candle is my
opponent he challenged me so he or she
challenged me from Germany do I know
this person really sure anyway let's get
rolling candid eyes going form a gambit
line here the rusev gambit I'm just
grabbing everything here give me all the
bonds yeah this is not a bad gambit I
think white has quite decent
compensation um in fact in fact taking
only form is something that I only
recently studied I think it is fine for
black but it is a rather greedy approach
you have to be honest them I still think
black is fine if you get to trade those
bishops yeah then you should be fine
okay why divides the trade here it going
is going to be interesting article age 6
and a 6
I recently analyzed that I hope I'm not
confusing things isn't it possible that
I'm confusing stuff but when I checked
this I thought black is extremely ok
because I have a pretty neat idea
so right now is looking for something
direct and probably won't find anything
and then we'll probably play something
that can be won because you don't quite
know what you're supposed to do here
you're not having a direct idea
to do you might wonder what a eight-six
is doing yeah I show you this is the
idea now the bishop is attacked on g5
and what is white going to play you know
if he is going to retreat the bishop I'm
going 95 1 sometimes you can even go
Knight g4 I don't think that works yeah
I have to check this now 95 yeah I think
I don't think it should work right 95 is
good it is important to play a 6 in some
lines because Bishop e5 is an annoying
move against King D 7 this is why a 6 is
a good prep yeah white is completely
running into my preparation here
basically so I'm going to take one thing
has to be said I mean I'm basically
winning now purely position wise but
it's still it's game you're getting
actually a little bit a bit of preview
here of my my e45 black repertoire this
is one of the things that are analyzed
so what are we going to download to take
just keep it simple for a moment let's
just do this
and going to a better ending he's got d5
but I can take it okay so that's not bad
actually c4 is a good idea my bishop is
not really having many squares available
okay that's that's probably the way to
go
a kc5 yam Ruby 5's coming maybe I should
be ready to go f6 how many Luke age for
was an interesting trying activate or
this one
and that's actually a simple decision
why not not certain that it was
necessary though which it looks like
it's going to lead to a technical play
now where I'm a porn up for nothing
at least I don't see any any
compensation for white yeah Oh gage to
also was an idea so be six I need to
head to play be six back to the Queen
side
it's increment don't lose on time yeah
you know it's one of the good things
about the increment I needed still to
show how technically how this is
converted technically okay so let's have
a look at them um it is interesting here
black has a bunch of options the move
that is very frequently placed actually
96 that transposes to a line that
normally occurs from a different opening
that would be the two nights defense set
D for Texas the same position in fact
taking upon him is not not statistically
speaking of the main line begin what
gets compensation you can play this that
is also a good move if you want to not
take and not transpose but when I was
working late just to two weeks ago I was
analyzing that or one week ago and I
looked through this and saw that this is
the best line yeah but really that white
hair says not much else these six
castles Bishop e6 and now White has a
choice we can retreat take or play rook
he1
I think if white takes and that actually
feels entirely harmless to me because I
have this sorry I have this good Center
and white is not really getting anywhere
them with this rooks he might get Becky
six it's also a line that the engine
shows but black is perfectly okay white
can do this after which I will probably
take then Castle short and White has
some compensation but not an advantage
I think um after Bishop d3 this idea
that I showed in the game came in plane
aged six rookie one and now a six yeah
and now it's actually quite difficult
for wide to find a good move because I'm
threatening King bee seven you see that
after age three King disseminates the
engines top choice it looks like I'm
cheating I know but I analyze it's just
week ago so ok Queen d7 is also given as
a good move but keen d7 is just far too
cool to not play it so that sets the
right one and now Bishop d2 is actually
the best month if I remember correct him
then you go g5 and the queen is is
offside you can go here but b5 the Queen
is trapped now you lose tons of material
with white Guinea 7s Fisk is a cool move
okay ninety five and now I just take and
black is clearly better that is
basically what I analyzed last week and
now just straight tread dread this down
to a better ending maybe not the best
choice engine wise but it is very
convincing it's just a pawn we wouldn't
have lost on time I probably would have
played b6 you know if he takes it on a
six hours have a look a8 get a two it
should be fairly straightforward when
okay thanks a lot for watching